navy seals
the toughest human beings on the planet
my friend matt
not the toughest human being on the
planet their hell week training is
designed to break people with only three
hours of total sleep during 6 days matt
struggles to get out of bed in the
morning
on a serious note matt and i have been
friends for a while and he told me about
all these big exciting goals he has but
a year later he still hasn't done
anything because as soon as things get
uncomfortable he quits and i hate seeing
him let himself down so i invited him to
san diego to interview some navy seals
and spend some time with them what i
should have told them is that for the
next three days they're gonna put us
through hell the last day being the
crucible the final trial that will
either make or break us i don't know if
i told you enough about this maybe you
think we're interviewing these guys or
we're spending some time with them
learning from them yes we do that
and they're also gonna put us through
some training that's gonna absolutely
destroy us
okay okay yeah
i feel like i need to be broken yes why
like i want to live a better life but
it's hard to stick to it you're a
quitter
that's really what it is
right
yeah i haven't made a video for a while
i want to make videos again two years
since my last video this is the reason
why i started this this youtube channel
it hurts me to see other people let
themselves down this is a fork in the
road if you quit now you heavily
reinforce this quitter identity but if
you make it through you're reinventing
yourself people are reborn through this
program but i'm here for you i'm not
gonna let you drown i'm not gonna
is that uh figuratively or literally
drown
well
listen i tried but
what though
are you guys doing get up you were
supposed to be up an hour ago get in the
plank position you guys show up late
everywhere you go hey you did matt do
you ever leave the house or you just
live in your basement he's got the
serial killer tan you guys have five
minutes to get [ __ ] rest i don't
think matt's ready he's still cocky
all right let's go
it's your last chance you can quit now
and know that you're a quitter or you
can go for 30 minutes and then you can
really know you're a quitter
so what type of quitter do you want to
be
it's a rhetorical question that happens
drop them down
oh it's gonna be cold
leon
what the [ __ ] are you doing how does he
know what the heck is going on you say
push up
and look at his little man
i want you to cover yourself from head
to toe in sand
stand up on your feet
all right stand by for inspection
your body completely covered i'm missing
here drop down
get wet come back here low crawl get
completely covered how long is it going
to take five minutes you got three and a
half minutes
all right let's go cookie time quick
completely covered you guys have to
[ __ ] work together and you can help
out matt stop just sitting there check
me
leon sandy from head to
[Music]
they toe a couple spots with them
what are the ways we do things we either
do it
right
or
do it again
say again
uh oh it's gonna be a long day
so the guys are getting started i guess
good wake-up call my name is richard
thompson former us navy seal we are just
getting warmed up and you guys already
look defeated my name is steve prescha
active duty for six years i think we're
gonna find the weakness in both of them
not on your head over your head
all right guys come on over here
so you're gonna start from this log
you're gonna do 16 burpees low crawl to
the sandbag 16 squats then you're going
to run over to the log you're gonna flip
it five times when you get to the
sandbag you're gonna do a buddy drag
come on no all the way let's go
time
7 19.
wow
man better beat him that was a lot for
me
oh my arms
keep it moving you don't have to stop
you got it
all right hurry up get over here
that's it
[ __ ] you way so much
oh my god y'all what's there come on
yeah
yeah
i'll tell you what
keep going
that way
i think he stole his soul right now
[Music]
i got you
yeah you feel sorry for yourself in the
water let's go we'll have some rest now
yeah let's debrief them so what'd you
guys learn how to pay attention to
detail when you're under physical stress
do you want to share something as well i
can push myself further than i would
think yeah you got more in the tank
though
currently i like i can i can try but
yeah you can try matter of fact let's
keep going because you said you had more
in you so [ __ ] the debris line up on the
start line let's go that last one was
just
it pushed me to my limits this one feels
like i'm going to actually
like pass out so i'm gonna tell you you
don't have to do this
you should be able to just go back and
rest have a nice dinner or you go this
is going to stretch me into somebody
maybe you haven't met yet
so if you choose to you'll line up right
here
if you choose not to then you're just
taking a few steps away
you do it
all right
become that warrior that you know you
are
everybody else sees in you you get to
see it now
ready
go
let's go matt look at this guy
who would have thought that's in him
find that person within you that's just
waiting to get out
look
yes
let's go man fight
[Music]
yes
this is what it's all about man
brotherhood the camaraderie and pushing
each other there's not many people that
can do this and you just did it
keep remembering that
i'm only thinking about the next two
days
first day really good love some guys
working together well they make it
through three days of this
we'll see you ready man 5 20 a.m let's
get it how much of what we did yesterday
is something like hell week it's tough
to compare that's the thing is that we
think coming from the outside that
there's some kind of like
secret to like perform at such a high
level it's more of being so disciplined
about the simple things when we talk
about the big four skills of mental
toughness breath work is a skill
positivity is a skill
visualization is a skill and micro goals
are a skill like when you have contact
and the stress level is way up there
those are skills that come into play
really fast that's why they're trained
at these times so when you need them
they're available to you so this morning
we're going to take leon and matt
through some pool work we'll have him
doing some drown proofing i suck at
diving i suck at swimming and i'm
terrified of this all right get in the
water
you guys are going to tread water
try not to use so much energy it's
making me tired just watching today
you guys are going for 25 minutes how
the [ __ ] is not doing this just about
nine minutes
how long do you have left
wrong answer
as long as it come takes right it
doesn't matter if it's 25 minutes or two
hours
all right leon i want you to have one
hand in the air
oh
[Music]
start doing the bomb up and down
the water is an equalizer like it will
challenge you and uh just like going
through this program we will find
someone's weakness
today
they are on a scale of one to ten i'll
give them a solid three
so they're uh they're learning we're
about to hit the hill
we'll suck the soul out of them right
now let's go
if i feel like you are putting out give
me 100 of what you have easy day if i
get any sense that you're sucking into
yourselves or feeling sorry for yourself
can hammer you until you both quit come
on matt
i have to take him
let's take it now
[Music]
all right you're fine make it up to the
top let's go come on let's go
that's it
you got it you guys just gonna run off
without your water why don't you guys go
down and get your water bottle in the
back
all right
come on
bro i need a
break right now i need to
oh my god
i think i'm gonna pass out there's a lot
more in the tank than you think matt
alright getting a push up position
down
do you think that was a good push-up
matt
get off your [ __ ] knees
until you guys can do perfect ten i'm
gonna just keep resetting ah we almost
got it matt
nice last one easy
[Music]
next time you're in this situation with
one of the instructors whether it's rich
or me i don't want to hear you guys
whining yeah and i don't want you to see
you put your knees on the ground until i
tell you to yeah get back up in a
push-up position please yes
holy
leo why don't you motivate your friend
why don't you guys take a quick little
walk there's definitely a part of
yourself it's gonna be like
oh i guess i am a quitter but now you're
telling yourself more stories because
you don't know how long it lasts how
much longer it's going to be
you have so much more in the tank don't
this is not about you
this is about us
with you in this [ __ ] right now you're
focusing on your feelings
focus on me look at me say this let's
get this
yes
[Music]
i can't really get through him right now
i want to but he's so deep in it right
now life at some point is going to kick
you in the teeth you know and it doesn't
care who you are what you've done how
much money you got what are you going to
do when you have an injury you get into
a car accident you got cancer it's going
to be you that's going to pull your head
out of your ass so like get something
done
okay so
here's the deal you either do it right
or do it again so this could be the last
time you run up that broken hill if i
see you [ __ ] walking anywhere along
this trail i'm gonna do it again
keep going
it's going
[Music]
right in front of me
i got bored so i moved your rucksacks
for you
thank you you have 30 seconds to work as
a team and find those rucksacks there's
one hit the other one
move it to the middle grab this one
move it to the middle grab this one move
it to the middle quick
quick go
let go
now you're going to pay the price
you could have just put out and had it
done one time i don't want to hear if i
can try
waiting for you get in push-up position
all right
lead them
down
one
down
suffer in silence nobody wants to hear
you complain you come
one
two two
come on matt
you got this
it's a choice matt it doesn't matter how
fit you are it's a choice
one
down two
down three good down four
down five down six
down
down eight down
down one
you guys better beat me down the hill
i'm going to give you a 10 second head
start
yes
look what you got inside of you you see
you're running you're really good at
running from people
there's one lesson you can take away
from today man you gotta find that inner
strength and just pull through some of
these tough times what do you guys think
i could do better
to
get through the mat when he's in
he's got to be the one that's got to
show up right you can only do so much
influence the only thing i can say is
don't give up on them if you really love
them because i think that that's where a
lot of problems in my life came from
just seeing other people
let themselves down and the pain that it
causes for themselves and the people
around me and i try to do it oftentimes
people that are just aren't ready we
would say
we constantly work to master ourselves
to be in service to others i think
matt's doing a great job you're right
where you should be right that's just a
choice on a daily basis what am i going
to show up how am i going to show up
today
so take it in get some rest tomorrow's a
test
if this was this has been a 3 out of 10
tomorrow will be a 9 out of 10. tomorrow
it's going to be
the crucible
i think we've got a quitter i'm worried
that
if he quits tomorrow that these two days
of hell have been for nothing are you
feeling
[Music]
welcome to seal fit hq
this is where the magic happens seal fit
was found to help the younger generation
prepare for seal training and from there
it's morphed into many other programs to
support civilians as well ice bath got
overfilled guys gonna help us get some
of the water out so we spent two days
holding your hand warming you guys up
for the actual crucible now we're gonna
apply what you've learned and obviously
we can't have both of them make it one
will make it one will quit who that's
going to be is undetermined right now
all right you guys have another 24
minutes yeah
so how long do you guys think you can
hold your breath underwater
how long do you think you render for
seven seconds nine seconds guys you're
going for 18 seconds
there's no reason why you can't do 18
seconds let's see what they get
that was more than 18 16 seconds really
yeah but we don't have time to remediate
you okay let's go
do you guys know who lieutenant michael
murphy is
he and his team were out in afghanistan
to look after a high value target it
ensued into a firefight for their lives
three lives were lost one of them being
michael murphy he went out into the open
knowing that he was going to take
multiple rounds he chose to go out there
try to save his buddies so we do this
workout in honor of him so murph
consists of a one mile run and then you
do a hundred pull-ups 200 push-ups 300
air squats mile run so when you guys are
feeling sorry for yourselves when the
push-ups get hard when the pull-ups get
hard think about all the service members
that don't have an opportunity to come
back one
no
they're going to make one of us quit
i want not to win
i also don't want to disappoint the
coaches
if they quit it's going to carry over
into their personal life as well that's
it
let's go further
who's gonna be the quitter what do you
think steve i'm gonna try and get both
of them
now shut the [ __ ] up and get in the
trunk
[Music]
you guys have no idea what's coming next
we're putting it all together in this
one block of training right here if you
guys put out
and you show us what you have give
everything you got
we're done
ready
oh man starting to hurt which is great
because that's where the learning comes
in now that i have to start digging deep
that's what they came here for that's
what we want to give them
just keep moving you got it
pick up that log
squats count them off
together
go ahead and do this until it gets
really repetitive and their faces show
me that they're starting to hurt that's
where we can start inserting the lessons
one
lift me up
pick up these sandbags put them over
your heads
forgot this mat god damn it stay in the
fight show us what you got i don't want
to see you myself
grab it man
time
yes
set your baseline
now we're starting
so you need to beat that time or we'll
do this all day we've had groups go for
eight
sometimes nine rounds if i see you short
stroking the reps we'll just start over
if you
feel sorry for yourself i will crush
your soul
oh i think we've got a quitter
matt almost made the crucible
it's all fun i think you quit now
this is why you came here matt right now
stop this whole thing
this does not serve you
it doesn't serve him
it doesn't serve anybody
do it for the person you can be
i want you guys to look at each other do
it for each other look at your teammate
stop thinking about yourself in the
suffering you're both suffering
on the line let's
go stand by
go pick it up
time's running
come on
ah
hurry up
you're going 60 seconds then you'll be
secure if that touches your head or
comes down we'll start over
three three four five five three six
pretty soon almost there eight what do
you mean get your arm off your head
before getting fun time no
it's down
54 seconds
finish the job
get that bag above your head for 60
seconds once it's overhead i'll start
the timer
45 46 37
[Music]
is that the best you have
do you think you did faster that time
you are
secure thank you so much thank you so
much yeah
yeah thank you so much
proud of them man i love this
love seeing people put out like this i'm
so proud of math coach steve has a
couple coins 20x it represents that
you're capable of 20 times more than
even thought you were these are earned
not given
now what has happened since with mac
check out our second channel where we're
going to release an update because this
is where his real journey begins
[Music]